-Welcome back.
I'm here with Gordon Ramsay.
The one and only Gordon Ramsay.
Season 19 of "Hell's Kitchen"
premieres on Thursday.
And for the first time,
it is in Vegas.
Oh, my goodness.
I could just imagine.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Oh, no, no, no.
[ Laughing ] Oh, my goodness.
-Yeah.
It was that moment on TikTok,
where they go, "Oh, no!"
That's it.
[ Both laugh ]
-Yeah, yeah, you can just see,
like, "Oh, gosh,"
Not only are you gonna make it
through the competition,
can you survive
three weeks in Vegas?
[ Chuckling ] It's like...
-It was crazy.
Also, I think, for me,
that's 10 years we've been there
in the restaurants.
And it's one of the most
competitive cities
anywhere on the planet
for coloring.
And so to have that kind of
jeopardy and magic
rolled into one
was so exciting.
And so I think it's
one of the best seasons.
I'm not just saying that
because it's season 19.
I take that competition
very serious.
It's a culinary boot camp.
And when we get down to the
top 10, top 8, top 5, top 3,
you want to employ them all,
and they're that good.
So it's quite
a heartfelt season.
It's a tough season.
But I used to get so excited
with the service,
because a lot of customers
got fed.
It's about bloody time --
19 seasons.
But one thing I used to have
sleepless nights over
was when they go out
on the reward
and they were out for 24 hours.
I was thinking, "Oh, geez, man.
Who's turning up
tomorrow morning?
Security!"
-People go missing?
-They went missing.
But we had
some very good producers.
And you know what Vegas is like.
It's an amazing place.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I was on the edge two or three
times, let me tell you.
-Yeah.
I want to talk about
"Gordon Ramsay's
American Road Trip,"
because this sounds
like something
I would love to do,
but I know it's work.
But you don't make it seem
like work.
Who's idea was this
to get in an RV
and just go around
all these great culinary spots
of the country?
-Yeah, I get a lot of flak
back in the U.K.
about the success in the U.S.
And they sort of call me,
you know,
"Gordon Ramsay the American."
-Wow!
-Because they think
I'm so, you know...
I said to my friend -- I said,
"I'm gonna show you
what this place is all about.
I'm gonna show you
how good this country is.
I'm gonna show you how big,
bold, tenacious, ambitious,
and amazing this country is."
So, Fred, who is an amazing
maître d' over here, sweet guy,
the only problem is,
he's French,
so his sense of humor is always
a little bit sort of lagless.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
And then Gino D'Acampo,
who is an amazing Italian chef.
We go back -- Imagine a couple
of your mates from "SNL"
from 20 years ago,
and so it's like joining up
and traveling across the U.S.
in this amazing RV
and just showing them
what America is all about.
-I want to show everyone
a clip from your special.
Here's a look
at "Gordon Ramsay's
American Road Trip."
Take a look.
-You've been digging
for 15 minutes.
We got one clam.
-Here we go, here we go,
here we go, here we go!
-Where?
-This side, this side.
-Are you sure?
-Put your hand in, Fred.
-[Bleep] [Bleep].
-You got it?
-[Bleep] No.
-Don't lose this thing.
-[Bleep]
Now it's all the way down there.
-Go down, go down.
-I've got it, I've got it,
I've got it!
[Bleep]
-But can you feel it?
No way.
-[ Laughs ]
-No way. Yes.
-Gordon Ramsay --
"Hell's Kitchen returns
this Thursday at 8:00 p.m.
on Fox.
And you can see him
in the special
"Gordon Ramsay's
American Road Trip,"
airing tomorrow night
at 8:00 p.m., also on Fox.
Vanessa Kirby joins us
after the break.
Stick around.
Gordon, best to the family.
Talk to your wife.
Tell her to call me.
we got to figure this out.
-[ Laughs ]